[Musique]
Yo
Oh
[Musique]
Yo
Oh
[Musique]
Je n'agresse pas et ils viennent et marchent
ça y est et déjà le matin tu n'apportes plus de passage
habitat mais je ne le jette pas
après qu'il ne l'a pas laissé donner
[Musique]
que nous étions en afrique est quelque chose qui
peu ont ce privilège
[Musique]
un autre problème que nous avons
identifié et c'est peut-être
ils déplacent la faune indigène
parmi eux se détache le lamantin qui
C'est une espèce en voie de disparition
critique de l'extinction d'une espèce
indigène
et donc cela générerait
un problème pour la biodiversité
colombien
[Musique]
nous avons vu la castration comme l'un des
options pour commencer à contrôler ce
ce que la population mais la
la castration de ces individus n'est pas
facile pour de nombreux facteurs entre autres
à cause du coût élevé de le faire
activité chez ces espèces
[Musique]